hi everyone my name is Shai Keenan and
today we are going to talk about react
360 a bit about myself I'm a software
developer at a company called 500 tech I
work mainly with react and react native
I provide consulting services and teach
various courses such as react advanced
react Redux CSS and data visualizations
and one of the organizers of react next
are react conference in Tel Aviv and I
hope that you will join me maybe next
year today I'm able to talk to you about
react 360 we will start with the basic
concept of virtual reality learn how to
get started with react
360 and learn a new approach for
integrating 3d views into react.js by
the end of this talk you will know when
to use react 360 and how to do it and
how to get started with 3GS and develop
3d experiences in your web browsers
virtual reality is being used in many
industries
besides games VR is used in fields such
as medicine education movies
architecture travel military preparation
retail and much much more
because of its ability to completely
immerse you in a scene the possibilities
are endless it all goes back to
something called lucid dreaming a lucid
dream is a dream during which the
dreamer is aware of dreaming and can do
anything even fly the first known
mention of lucid dreaming was in the
ancient Sanskrit texts of mandioca
Upanishad around 500 BC then around 415
BC st. Augustine presented to us the
first well-known report of lucid
dreaming he shared the story of a friend
who dreamed he was hanging out a guy in
heaven and the guy kept reminding him
that he was actually asleep in 1838
Charles Wheatstone invented the
stereoscope he found that if you
two slightly different images next to
each other the brain can turn them into
a 3d image this product something called
virtual tourism for the first time
people could actually see and experience
places they have only dreamed about
in 1935 stanley wine Baum released
pygmalions spectacles a story about a
pair of goggles that can let a person
feel like they are in a fictional world
this story is considered the first
comprehensive model for virtual reality
for the next several decades we got
things like the sensorama the ultimate
display NASA's virtual visual
environment display Steger VR and the
Nintendo Virtual Boy finally in 1987
Jaron Lanier invented the term virtual
reality and since then we've had things
like Google cardboard google daydream
and the Samsung gear VR all of which are
very basic and affordable devices then
we got the oculus rift the HTC vive and
the PlayStation VR that gives us a rich
experience but with an expensive price
tag those devices requires external
computing power and external tracking
sensors and as a result they are not
portable computing systems of all sorts
are getting smaller cheaper and much
more efficient and virtual reality is no
different a couple of stand-alone VR
systems will arrive next year and they
will be able to advance virtual reality
as a mainstream consumer technology one
of them is the oculus go that already
was already released this year a couple
of months ago the goal is offering a
standalone experience but without
positional tracking meaning that the
user will always be at the center but
with the 360-degree views oculus is also
working on two different stand-alones
the Santa Cruz the oculus Santa Cruz and
the oculus quest that will be released
early next year those headset will offer
positional tracking using on headset
truckers
something called six degrees of freedom
meaning that the headset recognized your
hand movement and you can touch and grab
things with within the scene this
headset are a big step towards virtual
reality becoming a true mainstream
technology
so now after understanding how it all
started we can talk about virtual
reality concepts things that we as
developers must know if we want to build
a virtual reality application so what is
virtual reality in an actual visual
virtual reality is made up of two things
stereoscopic imaging and movement
tracking so let's take a look at these
two images are they identical they seem
identical but if you look closely you
can see some differences I've
highlighted one for you can you notice
the figure on the background on the
right stereoscopic images are based on
how the human brain works it takes two
images that choke the same content but
from a slightly different point of view
the offset of these images corresponds
to the distance between our eyes this
distance is called interpupillary
distance or IPD for short in this way we
simulate the way we see the world
naturally and it gives us the perception
of 3d depth headset lenses are an
integral part of the virtual reality
experience and why do we use hazard
lenses because they position the images
on the screen at the exact distance that
they need to be to get the desired
effect the stereoscopic effect but we
our lenses are thick so they cause a
distortion the square that you see on
the left looks caved in through the
lenses the outcome looks like what we
see on the right so to compensate for
this we give images that are rounded out
on the left you can see the compensated
image before the lenses and on the right
this is the final desired image so to
sum up stereoscopic imaging by showing
two slightly different
images to each eye using special lenses
we get the effect of depth besides
there's Copic imaging the second thing
we need to complete the illusion of
virtual space is to track the movement
of our body all VR devices track head
movement so we can look around some
devices the more expensive ones track
body movement so we can move around we
can walk around the scene of course the
more tracking sensors that you have the
better the illusion of reality last year
Facebook announced the launch of react
360 a new JavaScript framework based on
3GS and react native react 360 allows
developers to build virtual reality
experiences with the help of JavaScript
as the name implies react 360 uses the
same concept as Facebook existing react
framework just like with react for
standard web apps VR
developers can now use the same
declarative model to write apps for the
360 degree experiences just like in
animation VR apps need to be rendered at
60 frames per second and this is
something that react native is already
solved for us it's important to know
again that reactor e 60 is based on
react native and triggers most of the
components that we use our react native
components and the 3d rendering engine
is the 3GS rendering engine for those of
you are not familiar with three J's
three J's is a cross-browser javascript
library used for displaying animated 3d
graphics in a invented around 2008 by
ricardo Cabello it decided to write a
JavaScript abstraction for WebGL and
since then this is the leading library
for those experiences so now let's take
a look at some 3GS examples from the web
[Music]
pretty cool right and everything is work
is working here at 60 frames per second
in your web browser and sometimes even
in your mobile browsers so let's get
started with reactor 360 first we'll
begin by installing the tool that we
need we will install reactor ISTE 60 CLI
this is a generator just like create
react up or create react native up and
we are going to initialize our project
by running reactor 360 in it the name of
our project in this case it's below 360
this will install all of the
dependencies that we need in order to
run the project then we are going to run
NPM start and open our browsers Facebook
already created a very basic hello world
project which they call hello 360 and if
everything went well you should see the
following we have a basic scene with a
panoramic image of stars and in front of
us we can see a text component with the
text with the sentence
welcome to react 360 after the init we
get the following file structure all of
the static assets are located in the
static asset folder so if we want to
load 3d models textures images sounds
this is the right place the entry point
for our application is the index vrj s5
and there is also a file called client j
s used for the application configuration
and this is the entry point for for our
application basic react component that
contains two views and a text component
with the sentence
welcome to react 360 and on the bottom
we register this component just like any
react component just like in react
native or react for web now let's begin
building our own application the update
we are going to build together
will present our solar system planets
you can ease the link on the screen to
try the demo right now on your mobile
phones or your laptops it's bit dot ly
slash solar demo and this is what the
application is going to look like we can
see a planet with some text there is a
menu on the right to change to another
planet there is some animations as well
and if we look to our left there is some
additional information about each planet
to know where to place objects and how
to move around the scene we need to be
familiar with the coordinate system the
coordinate system is the same as OpenGL
coordinates
meaning that y+ is up and we use the
right hand rule for rotation we can
apply different transformations on any
component just like we do with CSS the
syntax is a bit different than classic
CSS but should be familiar to those who
code in react native so for example if I
want to place an object anywhere other
than zero zero zero I will use translate
if I want to change its size I will use
scale and if I want to rotate it along a
certain axis I will use rotate just like
in CSS translate scale and rotate just
like react native react 360 provides a
set of basic primitives used to
construct user interface this is a
powerful feature of reactor e60
developers can use the same styling and
layout system across web react native
and VR which opens the doors to directly
sharing layout styles across these
platforms view is the most fundamental
component for building a UI view is a
container that supports layout with Flex
box style and touch handling view Maps
directly to the native view equivalent
on whatever platform react native is
running on whether that is a UI view a
div and Android view etc
view is designed to be nested inside
other views and can have zero too many
children of any type text this is a rare
component for displaying text text
supports nesting and styling as well and
image a react component for displaying
different types of images but keep in
mind that you must manually specify the
dimensions of your images here in
reactor 360 image dimensions are
specified in meters and it's not
possible to predict the intended
dimensions from the pixel width and
height of the original image so now
let's go back to our solar system up and
add a panoramic image you can create
panoramic images or videos by using a
special 360 camera or even nowadays
using your mobile phones if you only
need to set the background once during
your application lifetime this is the
easiest way to go to the client J's file
and to set the background here you need
to provide the path to your image but if
your background is dynamic such as in a
multi room environment you will want to
control it from your react application
from your components and this is
possible through the environment model
you can just import it from reactor 360
and again set the background and you
need to provide the path to your image
so this is my JPEG now let's see what it
looks like in 3d this is the result we
can see that we are inside the sphere
our sphere is the cosmos the image is
surrounding us so that was the way to
load panoramic images or even videos now
let's talk about the flexbox layout
system in rack 360 we can layout
components in 3d using flexbox the
library used is CSS layout and the
syntax is more or less identical to the
web flexible
but as you can imagine using flexbox to
layout content on a 2d plane is not
optimal for the 3d experience so it's a
common practice to layout the content on
a cylindrical plane and this will give
us a two and a half D field so in our
application I created a menu to navigate
between planets this is our menu
declaration a basic read component that
and we can see that we have a view that
contains other views one view per planet
and we can also see a text component
with the name of the planet and this is
our menu a view with nine views inside
one for each planet so we built a menu
for navigating among the planets but now
we want to make it clickable in VR we
interact with objects in a different way
than the web we don't necessarily click
on something it may be enough that we
look at an object for a significant
amount of time in order to trigger an
event other than looking we can also
press a controller in order to trigger a
reaction to make our scene interactable
we are going to use a component from
react 360 called VR button this is a
helper component that manages the
interaction state machine by default of
VR button has no appearance and will
only act as a wrapper to capture events
but it can be styled in the same way as
a view so when pressing a button in our
menu we are going to update our state
with the new planet and let's take a
look at our menu again now when we press
a button we are updating our state and
as a result we can see that the header
component updates with the new planet
name next I want to talk about loading
models there are many types of modal
formats available out there
obj STL COLLADA c 3d they may come with
a built in
Meishan they may come with a material or
with texture at the moment react 360
supports to f5 formats the wavefront obj
and the gltf so under the static asset
folder I have created a folder for
models and a folder for textures
what are textures they are images images
PNG or JPEG that wraps our 3d model with
UV mapping reactor e60 provides a
component for loading models called
entity so let's try to load earth here
is our planet declaration and we can see
that we need to provide a property
called soft we need to provide our 3d
model here in this case it's the obj and
also a material a material and this is
optional keep in mind that we are using
here a utility called asset this is the
utility from reactor 360 that we load
asset for us straight from the static
asset folder and here is the loaded
model we can see that by changing the
current planet will causing a new model
to load every time to make our scene
more interesting we can add animations
to objects and layouts there are many
ways to create animations in reactor 360
for example using the animated library
or any third-party library for
JavaScript animations or manually with
requestanimationframe so this is an
example of request animation frame what
I want to do here is rotate a planet the
rotate function in this example is
called in a loop hopefully at least 60
frames per second and on each call we
are advancing the rotation by a delta
and this is the result we can see that
the planet is rotating
and if we switch planets the new model
will still rotate around itself in the
same way now let's see an example of how
to use the animated library for
animations so when a button is pressed
we want to make it look like it bounces
a bit and also when new planet appears
we want to give it nice little bounce in
the animated library this effect is
called spring spring effect and keep in
mind that the animated library is built
in reaction 360 just like react native
you can just import it and use it now
let's look at the bounce effect at the
spring effect when we click on a menu
button we can see a bounce and also the
new model the new planet appears with a
bounce with a spring and here is our
final application we are inside a
panoramic image where we loaded an image
of stars we can see the header component
with two text inside below that is a
loaded model where we used the entity
component on the right you can see a
menu a click on a menu on a menu item
we'll switch to a different planet with
a bounce the menu button also has a
spring to it and on our left we can see
some additional information about the
planet as I mentioned before react 360
is based on 3GS but only uses a portion
of its features the main feature of rack
360 is the ability to create user
interfaces in 3d but when we want to
develop complex 3d experiences and dive
deep into 3GS we need to do some hacks
or try to extend react 360 to include
those capabilities in order to use
different materials lights and shaders
to access the different properties of an
object or manipulate it we need to
extend reactor 360 and as a result we're
always trying to keep both of the
libraries in sync and this is too
difficult for us
so now I want to show you a different
way if we don't care if the user
interface itself is in 2d and we want to
focus on the 3d content we can split the
UI from the 3d content so all of the UI
is the plane react and all of the 3d
content is 3js we are going to create a
separate class that controls the 3GS
scene now let's take a look at such a
class and learn how to initialize a
basic 3GS scene here in our class in the
init function we are getting a reference
to an element that will hold the 3GS
canvas we are creating a new perspective
camera and a WebGL renderer and on the
bottom we are calling the animate
function this will create a loop that
causes the renderer to draw the scene
every time the screen is refreshed on a
typical screen this means 60 times per
second and that's it
from this point three J's is fully
integrated and we can manipulate the
scene easily after splitting react and
three J's
we can use different loaders unlike
react 360 which only supports the obj
and the gltf file formats now we can
load different file types that treat us
supports like STL or colada or like this
file format that comes with a built-in
animation and we can also use different
materials and controls there and control
the properties such as metalness
or roughness we can load to the scene
different lights that will affect our
objects such as ambient light direct
directional light spotlight a miss few
light and many many more now we can
access the actual model and manipulate
its geometry the geometry is basically a
set of points that define the models
vertices and faces and here with a very
simple for loop I'm rotating
each vertices according to his height
according to his Y position
to make the scene more realistic we can
add third-party libraries that simulate
physics this will add to our scene
gravity collision detection friction
forces and much much more because we
have access to the render loop now it is
easier to animate objects in this
example I'm getting input from the
device's microphone and I'm controlling
the cubes Y position it's also easier
now to integrate different controllers
that affect our scene such as lip motion
or vive controllers but if we still want
the VR experience we need to add three
things to our scene the first is the web
we are polyfill a JavaScript
implementation of the web we are spec
that will work on any platform second is
the VR controls that will allow us to
look around the scene using our headset
and lastly the VR effect this will give
us the stereoscopic vision that I
mentioned in the beginning reactor e60
is relatively new and lacks some of the
core features of three.js
for a very basic project that relies
primarily on layout I suggest using
react 360 but for projects that use
advanced features of three.js
I would instead recommend integrating
3gs into react on your own this will
give you much more flexibility and
access to the full range of features
that the library offers I hope that you
found this talk instructive and I'll be
more than happy if you share your future
experiences with me thank you very much
and enjoy the rest of the conference
[Applause]